this morning las vegas advocates are
trying to educate parents on
safe sleeping environments for infants
new research shows the type of bedding
may lead to
infant deaths bianca holmen now live at
baby's bounty with details on this and
such important tips good morning bianca
hey good morning alex so
important many parents waking up with
their new infants
like here baby ava you see her we're
here at vibi's bounty with kelly maxwell
to share more so tell us about this new
research
and go ahead and take baby ava and show
us how babies should be
infants be sleeping sure so the american
academy of pediatrics just came out with
a study
over six years nearly five thousand
infant deaths they reviewed
and they determined that 73 of those
deaths could have been prevented
and those were directly attributed to
soft bedding
so infants sleeping in their child in
their parents bed
instead of in their own crib so this is
what we recommend
and the american academy of pediatrics
alone on my back
in a crib it's right there on the sheet
it's right here on the on the safe sleep
sack
so you want to sleep your infant just
like this no blankets
no toys no bottles no other children
no pets alone on their back in the crib
is the safest place and we got a lot of
new parents you know quarantined we had
lots of time so there's
there's a lot of new babies out there
and a lot of maybe grandparents who are
taking care of infants now
uh so what about the education that
you're doing to help educate folks about
slave
safe sleeping practices sure so on our
website babiesbounty.org
we offer a free safe sleep and baby
basics class for anyone who'd like to
take it
it's about a 30 30-minute course and it
gives you all of the information
regarding safe sleep and the safest
place to sleep your infant
and you know a lot of people are maybe
still unemployed they're out there
looking for work because those
unemployment
requirements have changed but what if
they can't afford something like this a
lot of folks are maybe putting their
baby in the bathtub or in the bed with
them because they can't afford to pack
and play
what are you doing to educate and help
those people well babies bounty is here
to help that's the
the message so if you can't afford a
pack and play you can't afford a safe
sleep environment for your
child reach out to us immediately we
will get you qualified for our complete
baby bundle which is
what you see here which is a brand new
pack and play
brand new car seat diapers wipes bibs
rattles a toiletry
kit all the clothes you see here we
offer all of those as well as this safe
sleep kit that includes the sheet that
constantly reminds you
uh the safest way to sleep your infant
as well as a baby book a pacifier and
that
that wonderful sleep sack yeah the sleep
sack that baby ava is in
and and she's gonna sleep safe
throughout the rest of this morning
while we finish
our shift so great information again for
those parents out there those new
parents and again our grandparents that
are stepping up to be parents and
caretakers as well
back to you guys in the studio great
tips bianca all right thanks so much